[Music]
hello there it's been a hot minute since
we had our first official look at god of
war ragnarok the follow-up to the
record-breaking 2018 smash which took
kratos away from the greek pantheon and
into the realm of norse mythology in
those three years kratos has been
playing fortnite a lot with loki and
thor but alas it's time to get down to
the real business of breaking down the
god of war ragnarok trailer to look at
33 things you may have missed let's do
this oh and if you haven't finished the
2018 game please click off now because
spoilers are coming boy
the trailer begins with the return of
atreus from a successful hunt his
silhouette is framed to show antlers
from the top of his head to quickly
remind us atreyus has a pseudonym to go
by loki we found out three years ago
atreus is both the son of the god of war
kratos and the son of a frost giant
another cool thing to note about the
opening shot is its similarity to the
first game in which kratos teaches
atreus to hunt but he's unable to put
down the deer without help in god of war
ragnarok atreus has no such issues
anymore and can hunt all alone oh and i
guess now is a good time to confirm at
least three years have passed in game
kratos may look the same but atreus has
shot up so much he now towers the dwarfs
he once stood among in the same scene
later in the trailer we also see kratos
holding this pouch it may seem strange
but this is a reminder of his last task
to scatter his wife's ashes at the end
of the 2018 game
it's here to show he misses her greatly
and even though their task is over he
continues to think of her
the first line of the trailer is given
to atreus time is running out
the prophecies say final winter leads to
ragnarok time is running out indeed as
the name suggests god of war ragnarok is
following closely to the norse prophecy
of ragnarok and this includes thimble
winter a frost that precedes the end of
the world and puts an end to all life on
the planet in game this has
ramifications for us all including our
gameplay the boat we use will not always
be available to move around the island
and instead a new mode of transport is
confirmed the wolf driven sled for those
that like names these two wolves are
called specky and swana the lake is now
a sheet of ice as the days pass by to
the end of all existence
we've spotted a few locations from the
original game in here which are now
overrun with snow but if you like me and
you don't like snow in video games it's
all good not every realm is like this
speaking of realms in the original 2018
game we visited six of the nine norse
myth realms and now during ragnarok it
is confirmed we will have access to all
nine realms the ones we haven't been to
so far swaddlheim where the dwarves call
home vanaheim the realm of the veneer
gods and asgard the home of thor led by
his father king odin and speaking of
odin he's always been watching us
through the eyes of his ravens hugin and
munin who can be spotted in the trailer
a few times oh and look the transcended
ravens are here too confirming that
collectibles from the 2018 game are
likely returning next we see the return
of freyja the witch in the woods is now
a key antagonist to kratos and atreus as
they travel through ragnarok freyja was
our ally in 2018 healing atreus who
would have died without her in return
for saving our son kratos murders her
son that was a touching moment okay it
didn't play out just like that but that
is why freya is now the enemy let's
break it down a little her son balder
still a baby was destined to die so
freya used her witching ways to protect
him from death causing him to be immune
from any kind of harm but this was
actually a curse and not a gift balder
lost all feelings which led him to go
down a dark path of hatred towards his
mother in a freak incident mistletoe was
the ingredient needed to reverse
baldur's immunity to feelings and pain
and well you know the rest to save
freya's life kratos gave chiropractic
assistance
freya's guilt then became an obsession
with revenge and that's why she will be
around often to foil us in god of war
ragnarok i will parade your cold body
from every corner
of every realm
and feed your soul to the vilest filth
in hell that is my promise he saved your
life he robbed me of everything
there's one issue we should really note
in 2018 we were told that odin cursed
freya to never be able to harm a living
creature for as long as she lived
well as you can see that isn't true
anymore so this should confirm odin will
be in the game as he is the only one
with the power to remove that curse
the other main villain of the piece is
none other than thor the visions kratos
saw at the end of the previous game are
almost exactly the same as the reality
when thor comes to visit
of course atreus is older and finally
thor answers kratos's question vaguely
are you a calm and reasonable person
[Music]
thor will be played by none other than
ryan hurst a man worthy of norse
immortality you may recognize him from
sons of anarchy in which he played opie
and more recently he played beta in the
walking dead thor is confirmed to have a
dad bod like he does in north mythology
so take away your aussie blonde thor and
give me a fat norwegian redhead please
chef kiss next on the trailer we finally
meet the god of war tia this is the
third god of war we know of the first
was ares in the greek pantheon who
kratos overthrew and now tia is the
norse version who is hella tall tear was
spoken of in the previous games and
helped the giants who opposed odin
although he was a god of war he promoted
peace and stopped wars rather than
starting them unlike kratos and now it
seems he's alive and well and hella tall
in norse mythology tia had his hand
bitten off by fenrir who so happens to
be the son of loki which suggests time
travel will be possible in god of war
ragnarok because yoman gander the world
serpent is also a child of loki oh and a
cool nod to this is seen on the clasp of
atreus's bow it's shaped like an s like
the serpent foreshadowing his connection
to yomenganda very cool detail before we
speak about the final character in
ragnarok let's quickly look over a few
gameplay changes coming we are set to
use the blades of chaos like a grappling
hook to quickly ascend to new areas and
the same weapon is used to propel us
forward into enemies our shield has been
given an upgrade in ragnarok the
circular shield is here but it's also
replaced with an oval shield and a more
roman looking rectangular shield too
this either confirms the shield will be
customizable or there will be multiple
shields to find and utilize differently
both options sound damn good to me in
one shot atreus can be seen riding a
mount but not just any mount it's a
summoned mount proving he is aging and
controlling his powers more as each day
passes and i'm hopeful that one day we
will play as loki i mean atreus i mean
loki you get what i mean
we also get a few new enemy types to
look at this crocodile thing is said to
be a dreki which is the old norse word
for dragon and i got to admit it i'd
prefer to fight them at this stage and
not when they're a fully grown adult
another enemy is the stalker which looks
an awful lot like a centaur from greek
mythology this is not worthy because as
far as i'm aware nor smith doesn't
include centaurs well in fact there is
the knuckle av but that thing is more
like a horror movie villain frightening
but the biggest gameplay update in the
new trailer is this mamiya's new ability
to turn pages of a book with a spoon
mind-blowing this is how sequels are
made from the subsequent interviews with
god of war developers here are a couple
of other things you should really know
corey barlog is no longer the director
of ragnarok he has stood down from his
role to pursue other ventures but will
be there to support the new director
eric williams eric has worked on all the
god of war games to date which tells us
the project is in good hands another
bombshell we have had confirmed is that
god of war ragnarok is the end of the
north series for kratos only two games
and not the trilogy we all expected it's
kind of a bummer but these games take so
long to make that it's a great deal of
dedication for a single team to give for
over a decade on the plus side the story
of odin will now be present in ragnarok
instead of saved for the third game how
do you feel about that and do you think
odin will simply be a side character or
one of the main villains and finally on
to another new character angra boda who
in north myth is the bringer of grief
that sounds great doesn't it but look at
her she looks like butter wouldn't melt
angravada is the soulmate of loki and
the mother of monsters such as yoman
gander and fenrir can you see what i'm
getting at here atreus and this young
lady are the parents of beings thousands
of years old which once again leads me
to believe a form of time travel magic
will be key to this story it's unclear
if this young lady will be a straight up
love interest for atreus or hopefully
something much more difficult to define
and let's leave her with the final say
you'll get your answer soon enough
well some of them
answers are coming i'm adam you're
awesome i'll see you next time
[Music]
you